six games vous prenez pour avoir fourni
de manosque a permis de faire cette
interview qui ont chaud merci aussi à
mine original vous devez passer voir
sachets n'y a aucun souci lié au
tassement paraît maintenant lustre à la
description
maintenant je vous dis pas ça tenait
comme chic et voitures qui arrivent
[Musique]
boxing et bien salut tout le monde s'est
remis l'original aujourd'hui on se
retrouve pour une nouvelle vidéo un
nouveau portrait du super ça faisait
dans le temps quand même
et là je fais avec une personne je pense
que vous connaissez un qui on va dire
qu'il monopolise un peu les cubains
quand même comment tu vas squeeze ça
très bien aujourd'hui et je suis en
forme après une bonne red bull tu vas un
peu vos booster il faut bien le dire
elle doit commander dessus aujourd'hui
bah moi je suis je suis content parce
que tu te tapes simplement accepté de
l'accueillir chez dante à beantown belle
chambre ma jambe des geeks tout petit
pas ce qu'on dira pas mais laurent petit
d'heure c'était votre impression mais
c'est vrai qu'elle est petit mais je
suis aussi petit nathan ne voit pas
d'accord moi si vous voulez la voir bal
avec le prix shine normalement vous
voyez sur les moeurs les émeutiers on
dirait pas mais c'est vraiment petit
d'accord ok alors tout simplement on va
commencer avec une question un peu
banale une question que je touche un peu
à tout le monde
le monde du jeu vidéo chez toi c'est un
peu comment dire ça a commencé quand ça
a commencé à quel âge et avec qui ça
commençait sur absolue flash ainsi de
jeu de jeux flash sur ordi quand j'avais
7 ans et après ça encore c'était sur ps1
joua they can avec mon frère et ma mère
cachée les jeux c'était trop violent
alors partez à la recherche et du week
end il faut qu'on trouve et on y jouer
et en fait ça a commencé comme ça et
puis après ben gibbard counter strike
sur pc après avoir joué le jeu flash et
j'ai kiffé j'ai joué à ça pendant trois
ans et demi non stop sans toucher un
début d'accord donc tu es un vrai geek
qui a vraiment touché ah ouais j'ai été
obligé touche et n'a pas commencé avec
mon nom en forme de namasté la gamecube
avec six personnages vont se mêler et
tout d'ailleurs une petite anecdote sur
ce faire ça le respect des séries qui va
choquer avis ou en fait tu sais pas du
tout où il apparaissait à un moment où
fil du jeu comme bolloré et mon frère à
ce moment là il est parti aux toilettes
et la joie beauty
il y avait aussi du catch up radio et
web away et c'est machin est apparu
c'était un souvenir car voilà et c'est
d'ailleurs sur leur âge vont se plaindre
ils d'accord ok alors davantage de
pokémon aussi mais voilà oui ici nous
parlons pokémon c'est un peu comme des
sortes ironise en multijoueur mais ça
revient à la mode
alors on a mal joué je vais pour marquer
que tu es un thé un gros geek à dire un
mot dur à dire jouer là bas c'est ça
voilà tu t'investis de plus en plus sur
la chaîne pour ses abonnés et aussi pour
te faire plaisir
ça a commencé à commencer comment
l'étude eh ben je dis aujourd'hui
j'avais encore janvier dans un talus au
confess a commencé parce que je trouvais
que ma vie était nul
mais nulle dans le sens où george avait
pas nulles nulles mais nîmes dans le
sens où jamais aucune passion aucun but
aucune chose genre ya ce vieux con la
passion de la guitare se passe on la
caméra ou d'autres passions ou quoi le
sport même quoi moi j'avais rien est
joué et où je me suis dit et si ça ça
venait grosse grosse grosse passion pour
moi si je me mettais à faire des vidéos
et tout comme je regardais benoît
diabolique sont fabriqués bis mode mais
si je me mettais à faire des vidéos moi
aussi et si ça me fiche sur qui fait ça
et c'est devenu ma passion à moi mon but
est ton machin et je me suis lancé et au
début c'était vraiment de l'énorme merde
je vois je dis pas le real maintenant ce
n'est ce pas de la merde quoi mais
vraiment à l'époque c'est tu cites est
nulle ou quoi c'est déjà c'était sur une
nouvelle de ma première vidéo qui n'est
pas sur youtube d'ailleurs j'avais
supprimé est tout simplement restée
nulle passage zélande à un homme qui
passe il tire une balle de snipe pas au
select partners là c'était vraiment de
la merde
et puis et puis bah après voilà je me
suis rendu dans l'humour et puis après
les intros irl les podcasts les trucs
les projets spéciaux etc
et au final un temps j'ai kiffé à chaque
fois je suis une vidéo je me dis je vais
mettre un petit truc spécial jean
récemment par exemple chez beaucoup de
montage irl parce que en ce moment c'est
ça que je surkiffe c'est partager
donc forcément je fais plaisir à vous
faire à commencer chez ouais ouais ouais
au tout début j'étais claude avec les
défis de squeeze mois sur la flèche
sommet du club ce qui a permis de me
rapporter quand même un bar à quai à
fermer un peu nous propulser sur youtube
et ses warteck aussi quand j'avais mille
abonnés avec qui j'avais fait c'est joan
burton mortel qui motive province et et
away et s'est du coup bien ces deux là
bas je veux gagner pas mal d'abonnés est
donc bon je vois qu'un peu fécond
mythiques comme ça vous savez un peu
boosté watts et la première vidéo que
j'avais vu de toi c'était une vidéo
parodie sur le tout premier trailer de
nouveau les trois arrêts joaillier en
fait je jamais ont senti le sol aride
connue avec le monde de moitié mais
j'écoutais sur skype et y avait un mec
moi qui volèrent bienvenue cortex et a
les crocs et nous des cortèges
voilà il fallait qu'il y ait encore toi
c'est cortès 411 les pieds c'est vrai
j'étais j'étais mort j'étais
complètement
donc c'était toi n'y avait que moi y
avait plein de gens qui ont cru dont ils
étaient 2 mais qui reste - en fait j'ai
modifié après comme un site il est
fréquent radiant et regroupe croire
qu'il ya de personnes alors que
n'entendons que moi j'étais là quand je
me tapais départ pas bon tu as raison
c'est un projet spécial georges c'est
chez moi et je faisais
j'étais là où c'est parti là et j'ai
fait j'ai bossé de 20h de sujets
techniques
voilà tout si tu devais être
donner si tu te situes tu devais te
mettre dans une catégorie de youtube
heures sur internet par le niveau
international les amériques question
dans quel genre de vidéos genre humour
vache orienté vers moi je dirais ouais
je sais que la raison que l'humour c'est
sûr mais après voilà après il ya des
chaînes vraiment humour humour humour
ils font vraiment ce que tu penses que
ça que ça alors moi y'a quand même dans
le jeu vidéo fin autant je suis content
tu vois donc sa main souvent rien
puisque je dis des conneries mois mais
des fois par exemple je présente les
jeux ou voilà un jeu qui je présente aux
gens quoi mais l'aurait s'arrachent
comme des donc vraiment hâte à grosse
vidéo donc vos projets ça a commencé par
l'epic smoothies ouais ouais ouais
silvani gros trouvé que ça ça arrêter si
je me trouve pas un milliard peut
chercher ça s'est arrêté au défi numéro
je sais pas combien mai mais c'est quand
jay z t'avais jeter c'est le trio allait
bien je me dois l'avouer cocktail mojito
rebelles fassent bah en fait on le
défait souvient on avait un par mois et
après même avant qu'à décider ce qu on
avait déjà fait une vidéo on le connaît
de la sauce piquante à chalon mormon
n'ai pas fait ça l'est de la russie mais
on va faire une série avec un concept
comme ça à chaque mois on a fait un truc
ça va être bien drôle moi ça fait des
grosses barres et tours les gens vont
taper des grosses parts
donc on l'a fait au début on a fait avec
le truc qui fit ensuite je suis plus on
met fin aux débats comme qui évoluent
tous et encore avec un truc qui piquent
et c était vraiment on avait plus trop
d'idées et puis on voulait calmer un peu
le truc genre besoin d'intimité
parce que généralement quand il ya un
truc qui marche les gens se précipitent
il faut louer vas-y vas-y superbe vidéo
ouais ouais on met tous et au final les
gens il faut même c'est chiant de
l'ombre
donc du coup mon calme et rue quand on a
un peu trop calme et même
on a mis ça de côté et puis battre dans
un temps on dit alors offert des filets
c'est parti hélas pour les as en 2011
d'accord qu'est ce que je risque
d'atterrir
si je me trompe pas les interviews les
faux semblants qui viennent de passer la
légende des quatre journées samedi on
est samedi la voilà donc les 200 me dont
l'affectation bas merci et je suis
surpris honnêtement enfin surpris dans
son sillage j'ai lancé ma chaîne youtube
jamais tous les joueurs du ca mais c'est
vraiment beau c'est vraiment ce qu'ils
voient jamais rose g20 mais j'attends
c'est si la donatrice
rien que jimmy l'abonné cc ouf mais vous
chez moi même quand j'avais quatre mines
j'étais vraiment reconnu un certain de
4000 mais c'est tout elle a descendu
c'est juste incroyable
ouais non mais je comprends évidemment
c'est simple au moins passé voilà cinq
mois je me dis je me dis comment c'est à
dire que imagine toi bon côté du parc
des princes aux supporters du psg donc
oui avant d'être complètement rivaux
mais voilà que je m'imagine au centre au
centre tu vois nulle du parc des princes
ouais et dire que ça 80000 places
environ
ça me l'a fait il ya quelques 90 places
et j'imagine que tu remplis au moins
trois comme ça on voit les caisses des
sables a fait quand je vais atteindre 76
mille abonnés quand je suis allé voir
stade de france et qu'on fait tout et
tout
ouais ouais ouais parce qu'on voit le
souhait et moi j'y suis allé et je me
suis dit tiens moment il te met combien
de gens y as tu vois oui joaillier 74,8
machin j'ai regardé j'ai regardé autour
et j'ai fait waël haj rien mon frère
habite franco qui est autant de gens que
ça que ça vaudra cher
choquée mais relate de 100 minutes
j'imagine cc poufre métal et 200 venus
devant toi ou alors on va dire injuste
les on va dire juste des 100000 qui sont
vraiment vraiment van den pourquoi c'est
pourquoi tu fais moi [ __ ] j'ai en plus
j'étais un petit tu te rends compte
qu'il ya des gens qui te reconnaissent
dans la rue des gens qui te font mais
prend une photo quoi mais moi ça ne
choquait qu'à chaque fois je suis là
mais non non je le fais si ça peut faire
plus de rejoindre leur parler ça fait
plaisir c'est pas un atout me faire
plaisir des gens juste dans leur chambre
donc franchement je leur parlais tout à
coup tout seul chez moi pour jouer dans
la rue je crois un truc de discussion je
parle d'un prêt cinq minutes avec la
personne chez qu'elle passe un bon
moment et moi aussi au final et puis
c'est ça qui est cool quoi franchement
j'aime bien aimé voir un truc comme ça
et qui est noble et tu prends conscience
sofitel s'étudier [ __ ] mais mais ses
coups francs suisses et c'est un truc de
malade et la west humanicité plusieurs
fois tes proches donc là on appâte à
parler un peu de la lady et maintenant
tu parles toute la famille j'aimerais
savoir vraiment première question dans
la musique
qu'est ce que pense la famille de ça tu
es proche des frères et soeurs ou encore
tes parents alors c'est mitigé
on a du côté d'un permis alors on à mon
père qui lui est vraiment à fond dans ce
que je fais là c'est lui qui m'a fourni
du matos est tous des nuls qui quand je
fais des bleus il m'a fait vas-y
continue et vas-y cette impression voyez
content d'une passion et coaching mais
c'est pas grave tu passe bien sur l'ordi
t1 rougui des potirons fait sa crête du
coup je les ai bombe à l'asie je précise
yves koffi et puis ma il m'a donné le
micro aux pédales mediatone il m'a donné
le trépied de la caméra et m'a donné
même une caméra hd et où une manière de
lancer à côté c'est le maire qui était
complètement contre les jets d'eau etc
leurs impôts celle qui est un peu borné
qui essaie pas de comprendre de voir un
peu ce que je fais ou quoi on voit ça
qu'à l'époque c'était toi
voilà c'est le début d'une relation mais
il a maintenant j'ai une certaine
stabilité au mature et puis voilà bon
c'est dommage même heure actuelle la
merde qui aurait décidé on a la chance
est chiant chez impliqués et elle est là
mon frère qui est qu'elle est heureux
qui ferait franchement c'est cool ils
hallucinent puisse faire des fautes à
lui parfois ils parlent de squeeze de
moi et me away et on fait plein j'ai un
truc qui va parler de toi et tout de
squeeze de bouger plus incertain et les
normes et est en fait il est aussi
choquée moi on est là [ __ ] mais c'est
c'est pas brusquer quoi genre c'est quoi
ce délire et tout donc cher ça et puis
et puis les lazy legz et si c'était ça
où tout est une machine que j'avais
comme la ccima à 2009 je n'allais quand
même pas mal des débuts est vraiment
petit à petit j en action des abonnés en
a qui étaient des potes de boyd et qui
verra même soutiennent g aussi puis on
soutient toujours trop enrichissement
vraie petite famille mais voilà il ya
juste ma mère qui est un peu un bon sens
mais voilà pas forcément un proche qui
sera qui comprendra pas dire en fait
c'est ça l'a vraiment quelque chose d
éclairer sur ce que tu veux faire basso
ce que je veux faire plus tard
j'aimerais bien faire une école
d'audiovisuel
ou alors cinéma enfin quelque chose dans
le visuel quoi un peu en rapport avec ça
ou alors dans les ans le parallèle ou
quoi
l'animation way l'animation voilà une
chambre basse avant ce qui me plairait
ou sinon voila si je fais le gros porc
flemmards de merde je fais comme un
salut
bravo nîmes c'est là exactement comme
moi tu meurs je pense en tout cas
l'animation je pensais ce kit kat et
caractériserait le plus ouais je pense
après c'est ainsi c'est un petit rêve
mais voilà en face quelques cassures sur
des milliers dans l'artois c'est en est
là aujourd'hui c'est que t'as personnel
tu as fait du tage vitamine a et voit la
fin c'est de la qualité au final sa
sélection voilà voilà c'est ça voilà
c'est ce geste ou combien moratois c'est
la même chose je suis passé sans plonge
sans moyens message après wells et voilà
les eagles il ya eu les os aussi effet
the way où il y aura toute l'année dit
le samedi ou presque n'a que quelques
noms qui peuvent pas venir ce qu'ils les
imprévus paella qui est de loin et vu
leur temps ça c'est la fatigue je suis
des louves gagner enfin bon ouais ouais
donc on va se retrouver à pleins paniers
tout ça qui leur a donc elle va pour
clôturer là on va dire d'occident
question est-ce que alors moi j'ai juste
une question qui ne croit
c'est parce que je sais je pense direct
on va dire la télévision à 106,1 moody
est d'accord allez halluciner adhère
gros coucou à brno pour les vidéos des
green day qui a été à la base un petit
pari en fait il m'a juste dit qu'on me
elle remettrait ses preuves pour aller à
la brayelle juste moins cher munitions
c'était justement qu'est-ce que c'était
prévu a alors été restitués non mais un
élu il vraiment les greens gaz en fait à
la base c'était vraiment genre il
m'avait dit on s'habille comme ça pour
aller à paris games week et et puis
voilà je l'avais fait et si on faisait
une vidéo vraiment une vidéo avec cette
nuit-là et un truc qui faisant ce moment
c'est gundam stade mais si on danse en
mode bonhomme vert comme ça ça peut
juste être trop drôle à travers tout
paris devant les monuments les trucs
sont lourds et tout ça ça serait énorme
bon tour eiffel sur les champs-elysées
et l'arc de triomphe dans le mythe rôle
important et il a fait ok du conte a
fait auprès d'une dame styger et c'était
vraiment énorme et c'est cela ma
question est ce que vraiment avait prié
vu que ça fasse parce que moi j'ai moins
cher que j'entends dire comment ça
marche et je pense que j'ai pu étudier
truc je pense plus que c'est justement
des abonnés aux toits emportés en
avant-première suture et là c'est parti
direct
c'est plus à cette musique ils sont
partis guaje ça ouais ça à bazas a fait
un petit peu ascquois la prod s'est
passé sur l 100 % mag
on m'a dit ouais c'est parce qu'ils sont
pareils comme futur ex moi j'étais là au
moyeu et j'ai halluciné j'ai fait ça
résonne [ __ ] mais sainte de jeter aux
orties choqué même j'aurais eu trois
abonnés sur ma chaîne au code ce je m'en
fous j'ai fait passer à la lutte et non
c'est un truc de fou fin j'étais choqué
notamment été la voix et après c'est sûr
vous êtes en live sur avec moi en bresse
manager 12 s'est passé sur l île c'est
une vision 2025 sonore est agi d oman et
j'ai vu ça j'étais là où moi je n'ai
qu'une panne on veut saboter mois et a
fait fermer tous les ces archives ont
tout donné j'étais là mais ouais mais
c'est un truc de ouf
moi j'étais choqué mais franchement
comment faire de cette vidéo matthieu
aubusson haruna on a suffit d'être au
tournage en laisse et on est en chaleur
si les trajets jardin je suis même pas
trompé mais le rêve franchement c'était
bien drôle c'est un gros projet grâce à
une vidéo spéciale voix comme il y en a
mais moi parce que ça sent du oui en
gros ce but on a un jour un bazar evil
ouais ouais ouais ya nécessité pour les
cent mille abonnés et à jamais bizarre
ici on salue en lui et commencer
toutes les filles afghanes pour l'heure
sa c6 et chez pas chercher plus comment
ça m'est venue en tout cas on l'a fait
et avait les courbes à la réaction des
gens étaient énormes et aussi on a
failli perdre la moitié de ma jambe
parce qu'en fait pour attacher les
couilles tu vas fonds gagne ficelles et
tu fais ton ta gens mais tu sers à fond
mais le truc c'est que ça bloque le
centre et au bout de quatre heures aux
halles bloc le sang ta jambe je la sens
plus trop et quand tu retires tuchan
plus d'agents qui a du mal à marcher en
tout cas robert beauchemin twilight
aurait versé ouais ouais si la famille
donc non plus sérieusement maintenant
c'est un peu la question qui va coûter
un peu le moral qui va faire chuter un
code moral c'est plus de toutes ces
polémiques peut y avoir sur ces
discussions même les gens qui
comprennent pas qu'ils sont vrais des
commentaires moi c'est pas juste le
large à renvoi de kia ya des gens qui
sont un peu borné en fait s'il ya des
gens qui sont pas leur propre avis et
les gens qui sont leurs propres alliés
ça la grosse différence un quelqu'un qui
fait pas son propre avis et qui répètent
jusqu'à ses potes qui ont ji qui eux
mêmes ont entendu dire un machin le
voilà c'est le mec qui va faire du bien
pour l'argent c'est la merde t'es nul
1-1 john tu fais bombe à ok enfin autant
pour vraiment à prendre a pas prêté
attention même si bobby gaz derrière
tout ça ce sont les tueurs sont comme
vous comme ceux qui regardent comme tout
le monde
forcément quand ils ont livré un message
comme ça ils sont [ __ ] c'est le
blessant du fait d'un imbroglio quoi
voilà ça [ __ ] je suis chimiques echa
et puis en ayant la même il sera maigre
avant question et tours mais voilà fin
ses comptes
mais après l'ag qui font des trucs grave
constructif qu'il faut moi ça me fait
pas pour ça ça ça et ça et là
honnêtement c'est juste avant celui de
son ouest c'est super cool ça tu te dis
ouais bon là je n'ai pas changé pour une
personne mais je comprendre à son point
de vue je comprends encore plus à plaire
elle dit ça te laisse pantois des gens
et moi la faim moi et c'est un truc je
comprends tout à fait sûr j -dc points
comme tu regardes les forums je ne fais
ça qui est de fous mais voilà fin faut y
en a qui disent des tout pour trouver
une issue logique s'il en a il pourra
prix là c'est du troll assez de choses
du chant dans tous les cas ouais voilà
c'est en haïti qu'ils troll mais voilà
faut vraiment voir les gens sincères et
qui kiffent on impute un truc
constructif négatif ou positif dans les
deux cas ça fait donc alors là on va je
fais moi cette petite interview d'un
sympathique
oui oui avec une question bon ces
derniers en bio les dernières vidéos du
tout a été invité par électronicien by
truckers une première fois lyon avec les
avec youtube heures on était sur une
belle opération en obtenant une deuxième
fois sur le nouveau need for speed most
wanted que j'ai surkiffé sa mère et
oriens énorme
et puis et puis well français
conseillons tout a pu rencontrer
d'autres tuyaux du gore jean ziegler ex
ddaf roxy que jordan et dark funeral et
ses chaussons extreme4 et c'était grave
couler une pure ambiance où des soupes
et en tout cas le sens complet et ou
franchement ça fait trop plaisir et puis
ouais bah du coup vrai c'est bien ça me
permet de faire des petites vidéos un
trouillard et le gameplay derrière a
commenté bien c'est une question que je
pense beaucoup de le désavouer
ces cabanes acquérir une question que je
pense que les abonnés seulement les plus
âgées les plus matures est-ce que ça
tour des portes tous à être invitée chez
electronic arts tu sais c'est que la
presse les médias lentement et là ils
sont en train de la vitesse comme un des
futurs barre je ne suis pas dans le sens
où il invite il a envie de même des gens
juste pour tester les a cédées il invite
déjà en cours moi je serai 100 mille
abonnés benoît des gens qu'on 2000
abonnés etc et on s'en fout en fait du
nom de damien sonar l'absoudre on se
voit tous
on est tous là pour la même chose etc
mais derrière où elle peut être que ça
peut ça pauvre départ je pensais sur mon
avis mais après ça dépend dans quel
domaine où un maire de la ville il ya
moyen que ça ouvre des portes
j'espère en tout cas que pourra être
court terme alors un petit jeu c'est
peut-être sa dernière nouveauté l'oscar
quoi la prochaine vidéo la prochaine
vidéo
ce sera soit en scène de soi et leur
prochain 2 dance
il va péter ça oui il va débuter vers il
va vraiment étendre l'honneur ça semble
à l'upci n'ont rien cassé quelque 4,9 en
dissident montant ouais ouais mais celui
d'avant il est comme ça c'est un petit
ami le voilà 15 ans qu'elle a pas de
souci bon ben je te remercie
je remercie tout les abonnés moi aussi
parce qu'ils savent pas qui chutent ces
amines original fait ce réel je n'aime
pas présent à sa muse vient en fait il
m'a contacté pour une petite interview
bon ce qui change par rapport aux autres
interviews l'heure j'ai déjà fait deux
interviews on attend 70 milles c'est
clair c'est du vrai c'est que sauf que
chez moi c'est du pur et yahia della
torre c'est un bon jour cadreur parce
qu'il faut pas les oublier a répondu
boulot derrière et puis à toi donc qui
m'a contacté qui est passionné des
hostilités je me suis dit [ __ ] mais
j'avoue les passionnés comme moi j'étais
passionné alors autant dire que tout ça
peut être sympa j'ai jamais fait on
pourra faire du noir et avec quoi
et voilà et je rajoute qu'un chien mais
je tiens à dire un dernier truc parce
que là je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
bonnes équipes qui vont regarder je suis
vraiment pas professionnel ce qui veut
dire je suis ko ce musicien passionné le
matos et simplement d'investissement qui
s'en procurer les cadreurs cd a mis fin
au chant et puis voilà après tout ça
c'est la mise en oeuvre à fort smith et
moi je regardais la télé depuis je suis
tout petit donc c'est vraiment les
émissions télévisées le montage c'est la
même chose c'est l'imagination la
pratique des grâces voilà que c'était et
c'est donc tout le monde peut le faire
moi je suis juste quelqu'un qui essaye
de faire ce que j'aime vraiment et donc
voilà j'ai fait dark funeral j'ai fait
buisson mode tour agit de la chance j'ai
fait d'autres youtuber boutique homme
suspect j'ai fait une rencontre abonnés
etc
si vous les vallées à l'évincer dans
l'expulsion de manière et franchement ça
paie pas ce que ça change et c'est good
renaissance écoute je vous laisse
découvrir
est-ce que c'est original
[Musique]
c'est franchement way honnêtement je
trouve qu'il ya un truc tu vois la
troupe est d'accord ok moi je vous
remercie
un dernier mot pour terminer peas et
merci à tous
[Musique]
mais
youpi
[Musique]
ainsi
groupe scolaire ferdinand buisson
moi aussi des retraités autant il est
très très salll mesdames et messieurs